my mom had to carry me in her arms take
me to the ER and she's a single mom we
live in South LA in an affordable
housing building
and there did come a point where I
couldn't go to the doctor anymore
because of the co-payments I have to sit
in my mom's arms so can we just cry
together over my pain and the fact that
we couldn't afford a medical treatment
for me
my name is Mai le Kobo I'm 17 years old
and I grew up right across the street
from an oil well which we happen to be
right in front of
while they were operating my life was
completely different
I personally got really sick from body
spasms I got to the point where I
couldn't walk to nosebleeds that I had
asleep horizontally because I'd choke on
my own blood at night I have asthma now
that's something I'm always gonna have
to live with I got heart palpitations
and I had to use their heart monitor for
several weeks and that wasn't just my
reality but the reality for the rest of
my community and unfortunately so many
other Angelenos
about 580,000 Angelenos live within a
quarter of a mile or less to an active
oil or gas well and that needs to change
when drilling for oil they use many
different chemicals that damage not only
our environment but our health as well I
couldn't open the windows to my own home
because I didn't want to expose myself
nor my family to those toxic chemicals
in the air we had to call the South
Coast Air Quality Management District
whenever there was a smell there had to
be nine different calls from different
households in order for AMD's to send an
inspector to come see what was going on
in the world those calls had to be made
within two hours if not there was no
inspector the inspector would show up
about 2-3 hours later and would ask you
questions he or she would say where
exactly were you standing when the smell
hit you and he'd go there to that exact
spot and if he couldn't smell anything
he wouldn't buy a live report when then
spices would come and they would ask us
are you sure you just didn't leave the
stove on or you know what they're just
cleaning they're keeping it up-to-date
you should be grateful that they even
care but that wasn't happening or
was it the reality when Alan Gogh was
still operating they would use other
chemicals to try to hide the oil
drilling smell they make my community
smell like guava citrus chocolate even
chlorine sometimes even with a little
masking the smells that didn't take away
my symptoms the inspector should have
put our experience and our reality ahead
of the oil industries my mom has always
instilled in me that I needed to be an
important variable in the community I
belonged here
as soon as we noticed that we were being
poisoned I started going door to door
knocking with my mom to let our
neighbors know about meetings to let
them know about city hall hearing we
turned ourselves from victims to
survivors and fighters we started a
grassroots campaign with the help of us
grounds of community housing called
people knuckles which means people not
wells the Los Angeles Times wrote a
story about us which captured the
attention of former US Senator Barbara
Boxer because of our efforts I am very
proud to say Allen Cole has been
temporarily shut down for four and a
half years Allen goes planning to resume
operations
but my community is fighting to not let
that happen we're fighting to establish
a 2500 health and safety buffer zone
between oil extraction and sensitive
land we're fighting to protect our
health our air our environment and yours
too
if you care about people like me who are
exposed to toxic emissions and oil wells
because of where they live you should
get out to the polls and change that I'm
still 17 so I can't vote but you can
vote on my behalf
[Music]
voting is one of the rights we have as
American citizens but if you aren't a
citizen that shouldn't stop you you can
still be extremely politically active
and you can still encourage other people
to pre-register or register to vote
themselves please go to vote this year